yeah I have no passport so I cannot
[__] go there wait you can't leave
the country no because you're a felon
because of very other things
I never went back and got a I never went
back and got a passport really but can
you why can't you now because they say I
got a couple in Seattle they say you got
a what a warrant in Seattle for what
like it's a a misdemeanor warrant for
not going to anger management class
okay
you know and they won't actually bite me
they won't extradite me but you know if
I want to give myself
1995. what is it that we need what did
you get so angry about what was this
about you know in Seattle yeah yeah you
know I think back to when you were like
[__] eight years okay okay how
frustrated you are oh you know you want
to move ahead yeah and then you get a
little bit of steam and everything
Seattle was one of those places that as
soon as I landed at
it was a nightmare
okay okay from the Middle Island in
Seattle I got there on a Saturday at
like two in the morning by 11 in the
morning I already have police contact
[Laughter]
if I just pulled you out of here one day
and put you in a city and all of a
sudden you're like why am I waiting at
this
corner there's no cars going by why are
these [__] sheep waiting on this
corner yeah you get on the [__] thing
and some cop pulls up to you three
bicycles came up to me
the guy like a walkie-talkie do you know
what you did I'm like not really I'm
from New York City
yeah you take your life into your own
hands yeah they had six cops there with
walkie talkies turn around you jaywalk I
couldn't [__] believe it yeah I
always did for jaywalker oh yeah you
can't Jay Watkins is a city limits of
Seattle it's 100 okay they gave me the
ticket I didn't think I was gonna stay
but I ended up staying
Seattle Police step out you missed your
court hearing so [__] jaywalk that's
crazy for [__] jaywalk yeah
and then I had a girlfriend yeah I had a
girlfriend for like six months okay
great girl and one day she says to me I
don't know how to tell you this
when I was in college I used to [__]
this guy for money once a month and he
he let me go and now he wants to be back
and I don't know what to do and I'm like
I need this [__] and this is after a
divorce I just almost killed somebody in
Boulder this is after a ton of [__]
going on
this guy comes to Seattle
the guy who wants her back yeah and
comes to a club and we get into a
[__] fist fight like a push can I
asked one question wasn't the [__]
crazy
the [__] was crazy she's crazy
you know we got into a fist fight I
didn't throw a swing or nothing but she
got into the fight to break us up
and I pushed him and that's domestic
violence oh my God he was in a [__]
bar because it was something that comes
from your house so that became a ticket
it was no big deal but then it like it
got thrown out
it got thrown out like we don't have
enough Witnesses it was a word against
whatever it's a fight people gonna get
pushed people are going to break people
up nobody's striking nobody yeah then I
got arrested for [__] actually
getting into a fight where's this at the
underground The Comedy Underground yeah
great [__] club Ron Reed 60 50
[__] years old on a Friday night I'm
I'm the feature act yeah the MC is up
and the [__] three kids come up to
him
I'm not like we don't like the show
Ron reads a nice guy in the way he goes
well I'll give you your money back I'm
standing right there I mean he gives
them the ten dollars back whatever
fifteen dollars back
and the guy goes you know what not only
is the show suck you suck too and he
just smacks one on read
he just smacks this 50 year old skinny
guy that didn't say anything to him
where the bicycle cops now well the
bicycle cops were coming close so I jump
on the kids I'm like you can't smack
this [__] I'm 35 you can't smack a 50
year old in front of me three of you
[__] that never done anything
in your life that's why you smacked a 50
year old to be tough
so we started wrestling and then the
cops came when the cop was pulling me
back I got so pissed at the kid that I
pulled the gun out of the holster
you know I'm out of my [__] burden so
you know I'm out of my birds so why the
[__] are you [__] with me
for Puerto Rican from New York City he
had my back but one of the other cops
saw it
when he went to Puerto Rican dude they
just he loved me the guy was cool he was
always upstairs
and now I'm on stage with my shirt
people I came down here to get my 50
bucks as a feature action so they're
like Joey are you okay to go up [__]
yeah my shirts ripped you still got the
gun in your hands I'm up on [__]
stage and the place is surrounded by
cops waiting for me to get off bike tops
and [__] and I'm a [__] what the [__]
now are you murdering huh were you
murdering us yeah I was doing okay you
know and then I got off and they talked
to me and they gave me another summons
but that summons went back to the
[__] probation department hey and now
they're like we want you to go to anger
management but in the meantime I'm
getting a deal from CBS wow the guy from
CBS is up there Thanksgiving to see his
mom sees me on stage no I'm perfect for
a [__] pilot we're flying you down to
La the process is in and I got all this
[__] going on and these these
[__] in Seattle want to throw
me under the jail then I got arrested
for a stolen car where but Seattle
possession of a stolen car I was selling
Hondas in Kirkland and they give me a
car to drive every night when they did
an inventory the car was missing I got a
rest on the Friday night standing there
till Monday morning then they're like
drops charges were dropped so Seattle
was just a bad energy place for me at
that time like it was just everything I
did was wrong and trust me I was no
[__] angel I'm not gonna sit here and
tell you you know I was living my life
like an angel I was out of my bird up
there so after [__] I'm going to CBS
how to step up
and go to court and go like we need this
guy for this [__] oh yeah dude think
about how different it is right now like
if you have even the tiniest bit of
drama around you they would cancel an
entire show in a minute they went to
court
the name of the thing was Brooks County
and they needed me because I was a they
wanted somebody Spanish that didn't look
Spanish you know how that goes oh yeah
it was still 98. the good ones yeah they
wanted we want a Hindu but we don't want
a Hindu yeah yeah it's a wire Mexican
and put Scotch tape on his eyes
like when they go to Benihana you ever
go to Benihana there's no Japanese left
it's gonna hit you with Carlos he's
throwing knives up in the air knives are
stabbing people the cartel is in there
he's cooking with a switchblade
hilarious when you go to Benihana
there's no more Japanese left they don't
want to work at Benihana
hilarious bro I've been like you have
this amazing book that everybody got to
check out tremendous you know the life
of a comedy Savage is great it's out
right now go check it out it has all
these stories there's one thing that I
just don't understand about your life
and it is why you go to Colorado
so you you I understand why you go from
Cuba to New Jersey I understand why you
go from New Jersey to New York